I didn't technically go overboard but I
did kind of jump ship everybody feels
that way about you take ool don't follow
me we see in the teaser there's a moment
where it looks like you quit and walk
off the boat what can you tell me about
what is that about what lead you to that
moment I was just frustrated and it was
close quarters and towards the end of
the season and in that moment it was
just kind of like one of those a few a
few you're cool I'm out where did you go
I went off into the Thailand night
hopefully to be seen again Here I am I
made it out okay maybe here I don't know
if you make it back it's a long journey
back um yeah so are you reaching a point
of frustration where you're thinking
close quarters on these boats I've moved
to New York maybe time to for a land
life well kind of yes and kind of note
he's very lucky that I work with Captain
Lee for six years now where I like the
freelance life like if it gives me a
call and says come make some money great
it's not permanent
what was captain Lee's reaction to you
heading off into that well he didn't
know okay so he woke up took quite a
surprise I think I think he was very
surprised when he called first morning
coffee and it wasn't arriving what was
the conversation when you finally did
see him again like I mean he supported
me no matter what but there was a bit of
disappointment on both sides who's
disappointed that I got to that level of
frustration who's disappointed that I
walked off the boat and I was
disappointed that I disappointed her
oh are you kidding me
[Music]
awesome season seven of Lopez I know it
your sixth how is this charter season
how would you describe it hot in all the
ways our deck crew is hot Thailand is
hot it's just a very hot season and all
there's a lot of romance this season man
you brought it up let's dig into that it
looks like there are a lot of boat
manses hookups maybe the same guy
hooking up with multiple girls what's
the deal I mean the ratio of guys to
girls
we have slim pickins so it's like kind
of bound to happen maybe there are quite
a few confusing love triangles but I
wouldn't necessarily ship any of them
okay dude I did that yes do you get
roped into any of those I do more than
usual did you surprise yourself a little
maybe I was just surprised by how hot
our deck hands were that was surprising
one of them I didn't even realize how
hot he was till like week two because he
has an accident he had his baseball cap
on but then one day he's washing the
boat with his shirt off like through a
window and I was like damn it's so high
like I just didn't notice him but his
body was insane I shouldn't be so mad at
me but like you know how last year I was
kind of like the beefcake of the deck
crew right he's like the least
attractive but that's how hot they are
like not hotties let's run down the crew
this year I want to know kind of how you
feel about everybody will start with
Ashton I think he did a great job
running the deck I think that the
promotion may have gone to his head a
little bit I feel like that happened
that happens in any job let's talk about
your stews we've got Simone yeah with
maybe the thickest accent in below-deck
history I know I think she speaks kind
of like but also very oMG she speaks in
acronyms a lot so that's also like its
own language mixed with the accent
made other public but I'm telling you
that you have she's easy to do
impressions up okay can you do a new boo
boo oMG like that for the King you
vacuum which like okay poopoo lol WTF a
big WTF yeah but she was very cheerful
and I loved her okay then there's
Courtney who basically says I don't want
to be here I just appreciate her honesty
I mean I appreciate do we all want to go
to work everyday no no anybody who says
like I just love working 18 hours a day
for six weeks I don't believe them so I
respect Courtney's honesty heaven of the
chef at first I loved him because he's
from New Zealand and in my experience
everyone from New Zealand is just so
nice like Australians are more macho and
Kiwis are just really sweet and
sensitive but turns out he spends a lot
of time in Australia that thing you're a
good cheap suit you know all chefs are
crazy in their own special way and Kevin
is no exception
I mean like I understand you have to be
kind of nuts and kind of confident to
take on the chef's role but um I think
that Kevin took on that role a little
too much you're not the special
superstar that you think you are oh all
right we've got Brian the deckhand
that's the hot that's all I mean I'm
like blegh I don't like have a crush on
him he's just like it's like a Porsche I
don't want to hook up with a Porsche I
enjoy looking this way to look at it I
appreciate its beauty even Kathy was
like whoa Tanner Tanner is so hot he's
like I could see him being related to
Colin from below to Mediterranean like
they're from the same area they both
work in Fire Island tall light ice
around hair but Tanner is like much more
of a dude got it a little bit taller a
little more 5 o'clock shadow and then we
have Abby she's just like every other
female deckhand they're like I want to
be one of the boys which really means
I need attention waking up next your
boss is the most awkward thing it's just
kind of being really weird that some up
the season in a word or two
why don't you describe it exotic
Thailand is so different than anywhere
else I've ever been hot weird hot and
high drama high drama on the high seas
yep
[Music]